So the recording is running against Erwin, there are still a
bit of technical difficulties h
somehow that's why I
missed out on another 15 seconds,
but well, I
probably would have wasted them somewhere along the way anyway, so look at what he's
playing now, yes, it looks like I'm playing
Catalan with white
Wars yes big ones between take and yes
he took so I'll get it
back oh
C6 C6 is unusual in the
position usually comes A6 but well let's do it
take away
first okay he doesn't have any special idea
about it he just wants the
figures RA somehow
Exhibit
yes so yes that's the question now but I
think I'll take it
better so now we've actually
reached a typical position in which we have an
eternal advantage here with the
bishop on G2 who is simply much stronger
than the bishop on
C8 so that can be done  It's very easy to become
a one-way game here,
of course it's not super
clear yet, but white has usually
achieved what he
wants here, so now it's going
back and this move,
okay, so yes, it looks like
we should try to refute that somehow
Knight B5 C7 could be an
idea
Knight B5 could cover with Knight Z
but then I have
E4
hm well let's try
to
play this directly so of course I didn't
cleverly do E4 here
okay
now Knight C7 swap there and make
Bishop A4  I actually
managed to play it so stupidly that
Black is halfway okay again,
probably
amazing. Let's see what's
best to do here.
Knight
B5,
man, yes, that's always the case, it's
bitter, in principle that's how he plays
No, that you're standing pointlessly well and then
you really manage to do it with a
stupid move like Knight B5,
maybe then also Rook C1. I do
n't know exactly what the
inaccuracy
was, can you let everything back into RA
then out again?
Well,
okay, Knight E4, no  It's an idea anyway,
yes you would like to
swap the bishop with knight moves now
but
that always comes at the end knight
E4 well somehow a bit
unpleasant oh
yes
now he has got the bishop par
but I I always have knight
E5 and can do that  the
halving
h I don't have knight C6 or
some trick or whatever
is my problem I still have a minute
on the clock no that's always nice the
position is now of course
great again with the one with the weakness there
on C6 which you now  can play nicely,
but of course it's going to be
a
period drama here again,
probably a little too long with the
quarreling with the spoiled opening from such an 11 meter position,
I really didn't
do anything because what he played there
is actually fine  not
so but I played it badly
Knight B5 in particular was really really
silly silly move
time
warning yes definitely you now have
a lot of control in the
position that's not bad
considering the
time
I would like to have the rook on C2 here
Covering the queen sideways is always
a bit uncomfortable
here. Above all, I have to
make a few quick moves
here so that I
can make up time. He can't change that much about the structure anyway,
so this is now the
ideal position here, the
rooks  and the
lady because it was better for me to go to E3,
probably but at least I
made up a bit of time.
He can't not move much
as
before when he does C6 with it,
of course I have to be careful because of the deductions on
the diagonal, I have
F3
that way  But I don't think I mind
taking one away now, that's
why I wanted Hal to have the rook
on C2 so that everything is covered here
if he takes it now, I have
two connected ones, I don't think he can
allow that, so now I have
more
time and so on  darm wing looks good now,
the king is now always tied to A7
I can now try to
make some progress on the king side, he also allows it
and is now playing
nice and
slowly t
Check yes, well I can't with the beginning of the game  Be
satisfied but when
I didn't have anything on the R
I did quite well I think so
I always looked like I had an advantage but the
opening was terrible knight B5 and
rook C1 cruel
cruel from the nice
position, well